a big problem with gradient descent in
machine learning is that it is slow at
each iteration you need to compute the
gradient of a loss function that has as
many terms as samples in your training
data set think millions or even billions
of terms
bill gates once said i will always
choose a lazy person to do a difficult
job because a lazy person will find an
easy way to do it
well stochastic gradient descent is a
lazy person approach to address gradient
descents problems
stochastic gradient descent works
exactly the same as gradient descent
except that instead of computing the
gradient of the whole loss function
you just pick a constant number of terms
and take the gradient of that
stochastic gradient descent picks these
terms exactly as a lazy person would in
a completely random fashion
in summary at each iteration stochastic
gradient descent picks a random batch of
data points uses that batch to compute a
noisy gradient approximation and uses
that approximation to perform a descent
step with this approach not only the
time per iteration is basically a
constant the memory needed to compute
the gradient is also a constant
so while each iteration of the
stochastic version of gradient descent
is less accurate than that of the
vanilla version
the fact that each iteration is cheap
allows us to do more of them
what is surprising is that in practice
stochastic gradient descent not only
catches up with the vanilla gradient
descent but it often finds better
solutions
and this should come off as a complete
surprise if anything using an inaccurate
method should lead to sub-optimal
solutions in the last few years there
has been an explosion of publications
that tried to give partial answers to
this phenomena let's go through some of
them one common explanation is that in
subtle points where vanilla gradient
descent would get stuck the extra noise
in stochastic gradient descent increases
your chances of escaping
another explanation has to do with the
geometry of local minima when a local
minimum is narrow changing the entries
of our solution ever so slightly
deteriorates performance a lot this
indicates that a wide local minimum will
generalize better to unseen data the
noise in stochastic gradient descent
will help you again escape narrow minima
more easily
but my favorite explanation is this one
if you look at one iteration of
stochastic gradient descent
and you perform this change of variables
then you can rewrite the iteration of
stochastic gradient descent as follows
taking expectations with respect to the
noise leads to
this
or in other terms stochastic gradient
descent is just gradient descent in
disguise applied to a smooth version of
f
to conclude this video let me just point
out that stochastic gradient descent is
by no means a miracle solution it still
suffers from some of the same problems
of gradient descent
it is just that empirically people have
realized that it tends to give better
results for a wide variety of machine
learning applications
and the moral of the story is that fast
and sloppy is often better than slow and
perfect i know you come for math content
but you live with life lessons
this was stochastic gradient descent in
3 minutes if you liked the video like
and subscribe and see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you